attenzione questo video non è adatto ai
deboli di clown di clown
io sono deboli di ragni c'è chi è debole
di clown
[Musica]
c'è chi cazzo ci arriva estro beppe
vessicchio
comunque non so perchè ho fatto sta che
gut aprono andava di farlo ok desio mi
chiamano un attimo preso se partito di
poter mi chiaro gasatissimo bella tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti questo video sono
fari j
ed oggi siamo su micron a play with me
quindi c'è scritto qua sono supremi che
questo gioco bello con questo club bello
in questa cura non sono bella
quindi bene during the night of you be
there
durante la notte del tuo compleanno
sono sicuro che sicuro io si collabori
jtq la vuole giocare bat neve locali
andy ai ok ma in guardarlo negli occhi
va bene non lo guardo a meno che tu non
voglio morire no quelle tua madre zio
problema ci sono tra le quattro candele
per risolvere il puzzle è raggiungere la
chiave che ti libera
ok non posso semplicemente scrivere su
facebook aiuto qualcuno mi aiutano
sto ancora usate che fazzoletti di carta
igienica perché ho finito quelli normali
va bene 06
normalmente il mio compleanno è lo 071
candele quindi l'obiettivo è trovare 07
che figlia no kat assomiglia tipo la mia
vecchia prof di fisica quando dovrà
interrogare faceva così va bene quindi
devo trovare 6 candele in realtà ragazzi
le candele che devo prendere sono
esattamente queste c'è questa è una
candela che devo raccogliere solo che
non l'ho proprio capito provate a
indovinare quanto tempo ci metterò a
capirlo si porta ma come c'è una porta
nasconda vabbè che figata
devo trovare se candele prima che questo
tizio mi stupri l'anno a fare questo
l'avevo capito
si è chiusa la via di nozze chiamati
cazzola chiusa allora la porta bene bene
no cioè nel senso
vabbè adesso faccio un altro giro che
gioco di merda lo brutto al cazzo a sono
tra vivo sì che bello che sono vivo non
vedevo l'ora di continuare a giocare è
bello se ti e mi servirebbe che non l'ho
guardato non l'ho guardato posso fare
una domanda senza grifoni stupri grazie
perché c'era scritto sei candele di
laika sono dieci decidi di 10 o sei o
cene un'acqua no questo mai organi non
ne trovo neanche mezza di candela porca
eva dentro alle 10 se io guardi devo
trovare i semi che di candele e poi
soprattutto sta porta non era affetto
sono sei sono se io sono il quante ne
vuoi la merda infatti capire una roba
che ti prego iddio allora quindi sono
sei per stanza sono sei candele per
stanza o cosa vuoi non sentire facciamo
una cosa io vado in giro ma come un
computer in una casa così rustica mi
metti un caso di computer piano
[Musica]
c'è chi musicista detto o la tua madre
[ __ ] non nel senso che queste sono le
candele che devo trovare ho capito e non
so io che pensavo che fosse un
indicazione invece lo sono quelle
proprio le candele ok quindi ho preso la
6 ho preso la 10 quante sono in totale
saranno 10 no è solo 4 aveva detto che
era un 4 lo ha detto all'inizio
quant'erano va bene ti chiudi perfetto 6
6 1 6 6 6 0 6 vabbè ma che ne so io
porca eva veramente tecnico devo trovare
il pure con non bastava tipo snakepit
quello dove devi rubare in casa per
trovare i codici volevo anche trovare
anche negli horror tua madre lo sapevo
che non c'era più cosa che dice che
prodotti rumori vi ricordate che cose
che dicevo per far sparire tipo i mostri
quando facevo i video tipo tre anni fa
dicevo qualcosa non ricordo più perché
se una paperella emo cosa va bene jean
perde c'era una frase che dicevo fa
sparire non mi ricordo più vero tifo che
tua madre [ __ ] colore dicevamo
ricordo che non fa ci sono già stato un
perfetto non dal piano di fatto grazie
ben piano di sopra una merda non ci
tornò mai
ma ripensandoci pone così male piani
sopra non mi fai paura effetti sono
abili sta minkia allora 6 12 quante
candele sono spiegami io non l'ho visto
niente non ho visto niente non ho visto
niente perfetto perché palloncini
[ __ ] è entrato nel televisore che
cazzo fa il contrario
il contrario di the ring e ragazzi lui
entra nel televisore va bene
è uscito credo sia uscito e vabbè vabbè
questa la porta d'uscita
si infatti è chiusa non avevo dubbi
guarda c'è la macchina c'è garage
veramente 484 è ne ho prese quattro
teste di cazzo cosa da fare cosa devo
fare e posso prendere la macchina posso
prenderla benzina ed arti fuoco far
qualcosa non lo so buche o per qualcuno
fece 4 queste benzina io ti do fuoco
ti do fuoco ti sei cercata adoces che ti
volevo da fuoco mazza che maglia brutta
no comunque volevo dirvi c'è una ci deve
essere un altro modo per me perché io ho
letto che c'erano quattro candele c'è
una pizza che che appoggia la pizza sul
tema che schifo anno questo il corridoio
questa è chiusa ragazzi ho io ho preso
tutto lo devo prendere l'unica roba che
manca porca la eva è la chiave per ho
capito ho capito devo mettere il codice
nuove tele codice dovete togliermi il
codice l casson le candele il codice
allora i numeri che cosa ho preso 10 12
a posto non avevo che va bene l'ha messo
lui grazie però non mi deve chiudere la
porta mi dai fastidio andare che non è
sotto prima che gli stupri grazie
permesso la papera e motel a lascia
quale un regalo mio che ti faccio
non c'è e chi minchia chiuso la porta
scusa non facciamoci stato della
showgirl veloce veloce veloce veloce di
qua di quadri quadri quadri carica
velocissimo sono così fatta ce l'ha
quasi fatta
vai vai vai vai cosa fa non si muove che
è bloccato se la paralisi perché c'è uno
spermatozoo rosso che comunque faceva
più paura la mia prof di fisica quello e
sembra comunque un altro discorso e
vabbè è finito è finito marco lorenzo tu
che porti il mio nome spiegami che cosa
cazzo perché realizzato in due mesi da
un gruppo di studenti grazie studenti
avete preso spunto dalla vostra prof di
fisica avete che studiare fa male perché
poi traumatizzano gli studenti e creano
questi giorni c'è proprio psicologico
altro che freud può accompagnare freud
dei ragazzi questo era ray whitney un
videogioco con il clown è stato alquanto
bello adesso c'è un jump finale come
minimo sono convinto hanno invece no
sono stati buoni questi studenti non
erano traumatizzati così tanto io lo
avrei messo va a vedere castori spero
che vi sia piaciuto spero che amiate i
clown
se amate i clown pollice in su per giù
le ragazzine video vissuto un momento è
un mi piace anche pagine di facebook e
copre tutta la descrizione cesare city
16 vediamo il prossimo visto dai ragazzi